this was once home to a family of five
the tailors all that remains is a
charred shell everything lost
it was kind of apocalyptic it's the only
way that i can describe it just a mass
black cloud
across the road
claire lived there with her husband
three sons and her in-laws all of the
things that we've collected from all the
places we've been um
anything that
my
my family have given to me over the
years it's
it's the things that the jewelry that i
was left from my grandparents when they
passed a few years
ago it's all gone
she was working at the baby bank hq at
the time and despite everything she's
back again to help her community as
donations flood in for those who have
nothing
meanwhile on site the home secretary
visited crews who helped extinguish
fires here and across london
while residents were also allowed back
and to try to find pets
power has now been restored to some of
the properties that weren't destroyed by
the fire with the village now open to
residents on foot it means that some
people will be able to return to their
homes for the first time
the cordon isn't completely lifted and
support is still being offered
residents have been through hell
um some of them have got their houses
and they're feeling guilty others
haven't got houses and they're thinking
of others
so they're a really strong community and
together we and together with all of us
we'll absolutely make sure that they are
happy
as we go forward
emergency services remain it will be
months before life gets back to normal
even longer for those who lost
everything adele robinson sky news
wennington